[Music]
alright here we go
hello my darling hi we're long overdue
for a long-form podcast just for the
sake of maintaining the health of our
relationship we are you just called me
my darling I think that have I ever said
that before never like in 25 days my
normal greeting how is that where did
that come from I don't know it's lots to
talk about
today it's been a while since you've
been on the show and I think a good
place to kick it off though is bring us
up to speed on what's going on with
Shree moudou life not cheese because
there's a lot of activity around your
burgeoning vegan cheese Empire yeah well
first of all thanks for asking first of
all I just want to thank everybody who
has been an early subscriber you guys
blow me away you've been amazing and
you've been so supportive and even as
I've had to send a couple updates with
sort of a shift in schedule just the
overwhelming amount of love and support
from podcast listeners so thank you
beautiful tribe I totally love you guys
it's really super exciting things have
been going amazingly well I have an
amazing facility in South East LA and
it's a gorgeous kitchen facility sort of
it's within another like kitchen village
or kitchen facility of many many men
it's like a compound like a commercial
kitchens but you have your own
designated I have my own space and it
has windows to the outside and it's
really super beautiful
so yeah so the update is is that we had
a little bit of a challenge with the
health department well let's let's back
it up even further because the last time
that you were on the show was the first
announcement I just love you just yeah I
didn't I didn't know that you were gonna
oh you're gonna announce your cheese
company now like it's is it real yet
like you're like yeah we're doing it and
I was like okay so the announcement was
made and I think at the time you had a
goal of trying to just get like 200
subscribers and this would be a man
group of people to kind of you know
learn the process of what it's going to
entail to put together this subscription
box on the monthly or on the quarterly
and in the in the in the wake of that
you end up getting even though like it's
not like it's not like there's been any
kind of marketing or advertising around
this I think you have like well over 300
right you know I asked over 400 400 now
400 subscribers so for those who are new
to the show or don't know what we're
talking about Julie is a vegan cheese
master it's something that she has
perfected over many years prior to
writing her book about it called this
cheese's nuts and an evolution that has
continued in the wake of that book and
its success and that book basically
tells everybody here's how you make
these amazing plant-based cheeses but
more and more people were saying that's
great but I'm never gonna do that like
just can I just buy it will you just
make it for me and I can buy it and
every dinner party we went to or
everywhere we went you would always
bring your your wares with you and it
would always all people and this kind of
birthed this idea of trying to create a
company out of this which you have now
taken from the gestation vision bucket
and placed it into the manifestation
reality bucket and since we last sat
down on this podcast you've gone from
ideation into execution you've raised
some money you've rented this commercial
kitchen you've hired a bunch of people
you have all these subscribers now and
you're now in the final stages of
finalizing the packaging and you're
gonna be shipping very soon and in the
midst of all of that there's everything
that goes into a startup the bureaucracy
the paperwork the kind of paper the
paperwork it goes with all the
regulatory stuff health department and
all of that and obviously there's always
kind of like delays and this stuff takes
longer but you have a very patient group
subscribers that you've been in constant
communication with and you're really on
the eve of shipping your first batch
coming soon right that is all true yeah
beautifully it's not a good scent I try
to bring people up to sky you know if
they just you know sort of happen upon
don't know what we're talking yes so
it's been amazing
it's been an amazing process it's been
rather fluid I've been in my flow things
are just coming together and really
really with a lot of ease and a lot of
grace and that is evidence to me of the
alignment of this expression so you know
I it's sort of a culmination of all of
my life experience and what I've
realized is that I'm at the beginning of
my innovation so the cheeses that I'm
shipping in the first sacred box of Shri
Madhu life it comes six flavors in a box
those are the new evolution of cheeses
so they aren't actually the recipes that
are in the book that I published because
it's always a forward evolving you know
process of creation but I'm also
extremely blessed from all the cookbooks
that I published I've created almost 500
recipes and then also doing all of our
retreats and having my spiritual
community online water tiger everybody
that is with me has worked with me
spiritually and had an experience and
this includes investors as well as
actual I call them sacred makers so in
Sri mu we are creating an environment so
it's not just that there are cultures in
the cheese we are creating a culture of
awareness no pun intended so the the
when we make the cheese you know I was I
was feeling into you know okay you know
you would normally call on my staff my
kitchen staff or my kitchen help and I
was meditating into that and I was like
I'm gonna call them sacred makers and
I'm not even going to ask them to do
something to achieve that title because
I want to name them I want to give them
that mantle from the very beginning so
that they know how special they are and
they know that who touches your food is
a key ingredient to the way that it
tastes so the sacred makers in our
organization in our community they are
required to do a breathing meditation
before anybody touches the cheese so we
are all plant-based everybody that is in
our facility and we are also all
meditators and I have a control
requirement it is actually yeah it's a
it's a cultural preference it's you know
we set an intention
create a certain environment and my two
managers actually have the title of
flowmasters and I just want to give them
a shout out Chloe Stein and Becca rife
they have been by my side and they
they've been brilliant just absolutely
brilliant brilliant what's your title my
title is actually mother arc you could
do business scars and put that on I
don't know mother arc yeah a RC arc at
its era see but it kind of has a double
meaning you know and matter the whole
you're the vessel it's a you know Sri
Mazar frequency so so when I talk about
it there's the business mission so the
business mission is to create the most
delicious artisanal cheeses on planet
earth not vegan cheese's just cheese's
so Sri mu is the new evolution of cheese
it's better than cheese it's not cheese
it's a devotional offering but that goes
along with that is the sacred mission or
the secret mission is to give everybody
a frequency and an opportunity of
awakening into the beauty of who they
are and so within everything we do it
has energy signatures or frequency and
so Sri mu is a carrier of this intention
this devotion this prayer that I have
for Humanity to awaken into who they
really are
right and in your facility you found
these super dope like outfits or uniform
cause you got to wear like a certain
kind of clothing if you're gonna be
doing food right so you found these like
Japanese jumps black jumpsuits that look
like they're out it like this is if you
watch a James Bond movie like all that
you know and there's there in some some
underground layer where the bad guy is
they're all wearing like some kind of
really cool like it kind of looks like
that
well it's me you know I mean the brand
is about aesthetic and you know this is
moments of our lives one of the reasons
that I made sure that I was able to get
a facility with actually windows to the
outside is that you spend a lot of hours
making cheese and you want the
environment to be in alignment with the
brand so I'm a fashion designer and I
care about design and aesthetic and I
don't want people to feel like they're
wearing some
that's that's not pleasing to them or
not comfortable or not functional but
also just not beautiful so we found
these amazing jumpsuits and we are
mission based so everybody there is very
clear about the mission and so they're
sort of like flight suits right they
look like fun yeah and then we were able
to get like we're wearing like black
sort of stocking caps rather than you
know ugly hair nets and you know there's
requirements you have - beard nuts and
things like that so need like a cool
patch we do we do they say sacred makers
they say mother art I haven't seen but
they say faster yeah and they're black
and gold they're in alignment and you're
like piping in like bird songs and stuff
like that yeah so the sound environment
that we've created in the facility is
all nature sounds so you know Sri mu is
a is a movement in service to planet
Earth and to remind us how sacred our
planet is and how much love and care we
need to offer her so we play just a loop
of nature sounds from all over the
planet it could be the Amazon it could
be thunder it could be ocean waves it
could be Dalton dolphins it could be
whales but that's playing constantly we
also infuse an essence of orange blossom
into the air so we have diffusers going
because you know when I was touring in
facilities to rent I was shocked at the
environments where our food is prepared
and it really gave me pause because
there's a lot of facilities that are not
very clean and they smell horrible and
you're like and you think like oh my
goodness like I get something in a
package and I think it was prepared in a
clean facility and there are rules but
you know you can go beyond that so my
intention is to create an environment
that is very supportive to the team and
that the hours they spend in the Sriman
culture is going to be like wings for
what they do in the rest of their lives
so we have many artists we have fine
artists we have musicians and Sri mu is
about giving them that support sort of
that spiritual foundation and everyone
is very excited and very committed
they're really happy to be a part of
something that is focused on meaningful
change and so the spirit in the facility
has been very high have people just
showing up early they can't wait to get
in so it's been really cool and the
other thing that's coming that I haven't
executed yet is I contacted a nature
photographer named Andrew Souter or
stutter and he does beautiful beautiful
nature photographs and so I'm licensing
three of his images to of the Columbia
Gorge and they're beautiful
you know river in the forest with the
greens so that we can really viscerally
remember this planet that we're serve
you license them for what like to be put
on the wall like a big mural paper
exactly yeah and you can't there's all
these weird things about like what you
can and can't say or call it like you so
you're just steering clear of the word
cheese pretty much all together like
instead of saying this is a camembert
and this is a blue and this is a
mozzarella you came up with these names
like birdie and yeah so there are six
flavors so there's a truffle a cashew
truffle infused elegant this is an aged
wheel and it's called Bertie BER T ie
there's another flavor that's called
spire which is blue inspired but it's
made blue with spirulina there's another
flavor that's called elder which has a
food-grade activated charcoal in it I
also do a smoked almond cheddar ball
which is not your grandma's I can't not
cheese ball it's a not cheese but it's
called bonfire and then I also have a
jar of it's called cloud nine so it's
cashew balls floating in salted crystal
waters and it's it's this fresh thing so
I am calling it not cheese on the label
it has to be called nut spread on the
back but because I'm doing wholesale I'm
not sorry I'm doing retail I'm not doing
wholesale I have a little bit more
leeway so I've been able to really make
this a creative offering to the
subscription to the subscribers who are
my beloved tribe and and my priority
right so when you subscribe
you get you can you sign up and you can
get a delivery either quarterly or
monthly right get it monthly every other
month or quarterly three option you get
six cheese's in this beautiful five six
cheese in the box I had to do some Ria's
were this first of all the packaging and
the weight of the box so this had to be
reimagined a couple times which is what
what the time leg was I mean really I'm
really good I said the last two weeks of
November and we start shipping December
9th so I feel pretty proud about that
that's a real high execution and
especially at the level and the way the
cheese's are coming out they're just
beautiful so in a box you have a jar of
the cloud 9 which is the clouds floating
in water you have the smoked almond
cheddar which is bonfire and you have
four wheels this month so there's two
Bertie and then one spire and one elder
right well the cool thing there's a
bunch of cool things but one of the cool
things is that I've seen you like this
this has come together like once you
committed to this it really has been as
if the universe conspired to support it
like it's happened for very quickly and
all the things that you kind of needed
to have happen that are huge hurdles for
anybody who's trying to you know foster
a start-up have all kind of come
together very fluidly and easily which
is I think I you know I see that as an
indication that this is the right thing
for you and with that I've seen a shift
in you like your disposition your
personality to be you know very kind of
empowered like you're standing in your
power like this is right you have a
direction you have a like a Northstar
and everything is kind of like
congealing around that to support you
and it's been cool and I think it's been
great for our relationship to like you
have this thing that's really exciting
for you that is connecting with people
and it's been fun to kind of just
observe that yeah it's true I mean it
you know I think that all of my
experience having been a fashion
designer and and been you know had my
own company and gone
through production and all of that and
then all of the spiritual work that I've
done all of the recipes that I've
created the books the retreats like
everything sort of led me up to this
moment and so it's almost like
everything was already prepared and
that's why it was effortless because all
of that all of that preparation you know
it wasn't overnight it's been years yeah
it's not like you had an idea recently
like this has been an idea in your mind
but the execution part of it is fairly
but I will say to that I have I feel
that I've gone through a big expansion
since July and I'm definitely in another
level of life embodiment which is you
know what I call it for me and it's this
alignment that is so precise that is so
undeniably me
and so undeniably in alignment with who
I am that allows me to care for this
this mission as a very worthy steward
you know in the past I may have been
sort of spontaneous or made decisions
very quickly and it's been very quick
but I've been very very protective of
her and very unwavering it's very clear
to me what the mission is and what the
journey is and I'm very connected to my
intuition and I know I know
the beauty the power and the importance
of this opportunity and it's a different
me it's a different I've been able to
stand in this alignment in ways even in
finance or negotiating you know equity
things like that which it's it's it's
not a hardness it's a note it's just a
knowing it's a knowing of what is right
and I feel I have a responsibility to
this product this mission Sri mu is an
energy and it's like I serve her and so
it's it's beyond Julie the personality
and its really mission focus right one
of the most fun things is when you do
these tastings like whether you know
we're going over over to a friend's
house you know people that that aren't
you know on the plant-based tip
and you have an opportunity to share
what you're doing with them and Dakota
or or like you know that you've done a
couple events like Mercado sagrado the
other weekend where you have people kind
of sniffing around it but skeptical like
what is this and I don't know or they
haven't they've had an experience with
plant-based cheese in the past and you
know that comes with a certain you know
baggage or expectation and and then to
gauge like watch to observe them taste
it and then their facial changes that
happen I mean it's it's a unanimous
thing right
I mean basically every single person
that has tasted this or tested it has
walked away like alone away so it's
really fun for me at Mercado sagrado and
actually wish that I had had a camera
because the amount of the facial
expressions in support and in the thumbs
up of Sri mu and the way it would taste
it was shocking actually it was even
even surprising me even though I've seen
it time and time and time again and
yesterday for instance I was at an event
at a oka studio called be crystal clear
and it was a women's entrepreneur
bizarre like gathering holiday and I had
during the afternoon of two hours I had
women that were Italian Spanish Swiss
Swedish German all give me the Bravo for
my cheese and that is the the confidence
and the the vote that you know is really
really means something because these are
cheese cultures I mean no pun intended
again but yeah it's been really really
amazing
I've had a few people refuse samples who
have made the statement that they don't
eat plant-based food but other than them
I haven't had anybody be disappointed in
the taste food another they only eat
animal products I don't know I think I
think what that is is is I think what
they're really saying it I mean look you
know there's only a very small number of
people that don't eat plant-based foods
and we all we all eat plants yeah I
think what they're saying is they're
that's based on and as some
this is a highly processed product
because if you go to the store and you
look at what's available in terms of
plant-based foods or meat analogues or
you know dairy analogues they're all you
know packed with lots of preservatives
and artificial flavoring and colors and
things like that so I would suspect that
that's a reaction like they're thinking
oh this is something and there's no way
it could taste that good unless you put
all kinds of crazy chemicals in it right
I mean they didn't taste it if they had
tasted it they would have known they
were yeah I think you need to put you
need to make front and center that this
is a natural there is no there is none
of that stuff in it I mean it's it's
actually shocking how few ingredients
are Angliss thing exactly it's
definitely a mastery of simplicity and a
pureness so you can read the ingredients
you know online and it's it's it's
really it's very simple and very pure
and very beautiful so well I'm super
excited for you to see this thing take
flight for those that are interested in
learning more
shree muqaam that's our IMU comm you can
go there and learn all about it and all
that kind of stuff and I'll put a link
up in the shown us to that but I want to
switch gears here for a minute it is
November 24th today when we're recording
this this is going to go up it's going
to publish on December 11th right in the
lead up the thick of holiday season that
we're now embarking upon and we kind of
have an annual tradition of doing a
podcast together to help people kind of
navigate the vicissitudes and landmines
that befall us this time of year but
before we kind of dive into that I
posted on Instagram the other day and
and Twitter maybe a week earlier that
I'm taking my first break in seven years
which I'm very excited about I'm going
to places unknown on December 3rd but
I'm really pulling the plug on work at
Thanksgiving and I'm gonna be kind of
disappearing until first week of January
well I know well I know where you are
you will know where I am
I don't need to advertise
where I'm going I mean I'm not gonna
listen you know just because I'm doing
this doesn't mean I'm not gonna throw up
an Instagram post here and there do a
story or tweet or whatever but I am
gonna be making a hard and fast rule
around work and the truth is that and I
said this in the post but for those that
that didn't maybe didn't see that I've
been running and gunning for literally
seven years straight from the beginning
of this podcast and it's a seven day a
week job like I've posted every Sunday
night since we began this we tried to
shift the schedule a little bit and
change that date and it didn't really
work so well so we went back to Sunday
night which means I basically work you
know every Sunday you know like I'm I'm
working pretty much most of the day on
Sunday and I think there's an I sense
that like oh you just do these podcasts
and they go up but maybe that's how some
people do it but that's not our process
I have amazing team of people that I
work with but it's very you know I'm
very hands-on and it's it's quite all
consuming to do six episodes a month on
top of all the other things that I'm
doing professionally and then just you
know trying to make sure that I stay
married to you and be a present parent
to our kids
that's important and having two
households during the week where you
know either you're downtown or on
downtown with our elder daughter which
is something we've talked about in the
past like it's been complicated it's
been challenging and and over this seven
year period I'm very proud of what we
have co-created but it's been a ton of
work you know and I really haven't taken
a break I get to travel to all these
cool places and meet all these cool
people but it is invariably tied to some
kind of work commitment and certainly I
take a day here and there whatever or
I'll duck out and go to a matinee I take
little breaks but I'd never have taken a
real vacation where I'm like okay I'm
totally tapping out or anything extended
so this is long overdue I'm very excited
about it and I desperately need to
recharge I wouldn't say that I'm burned
out I'm definitely not burned out but
I've sensed over the line
couple months that I'm just tired you
know and and I go into these interviews
just slightly less enthusiastic than I
should be or that I would prefer to be
and I want to be in love with the
process and I want to be excited and
exuberant and enthusiastic when I sit
down across the table from a guest I
think I owe them that I think I owe the
audience that and in order to play the
long game and take out an insurance
policy that will allow me to continue to
do this like you have to take breaks and
that gestation period is important for
so many reasons not just to rest my
physical body but to really allow myself
to ruminate to have this space so that I
can begin to put the pieces together on
what the next thing is or what it is
that I really want to manifest and
create in this world and when I'm just
in the daily Gestalt of trying to do the
show and get the show up my vision
extends only to what I have to get done
that day and not to the bigger picture
of like why am I even doing this or what
it what is it that I'm actually trying
to accomplish here what is the mission
statement and in order to really get
clarity and refine that clarity you know
I'm gonna take this break and it's a
little scary because you know I said
this an Instagram post like if I lived
alone I would work more like I love it
like it's not like I'd read it like I
loved it I would work all the time you
know and that's another indication why I
need to pull the ripcord and get a
little perspective on this definitely
well it's well deserved and you know
everybody needs time to recharge so you
know it's gonna be fun to see what you
discover what you uncover and you know
you you have a lot to say you have a lot
of other things to share besides the
podcast you know you're a brilliant
writer and you know there are many many
other expressions that are there for you
if you want to bring them through but as
you said if you're only focused on the
pot
caste and you never take breaks you
don't have this space for those
inspirations to come in yeah like to
rats or muck but like there's no time
you know there's no time right now and
I've got to reconfigure some things to
provide a little extra space so I can do
things you know that are important that
are outside of you know just what I do
when I sit down at this table and thank
you for all the beautiful beautiful work
that you've put out and that you've
created and it's affected many many many
people and I know that many people
listening to this are agreeing with what
I'm saying right now really really this
offering has been profoundly impactful
on many people's lives so thank you for
that
but we would like you to still be around
yeah and the thing is like can I do it
like am I gonna be able to resist like
checking my email am I gonna like that's
the test like that's like ooh that makes
me uncomfortable another reason why I
need to do this yeah definitely and
maybe then after this reset and you know
you really worked the entire year to be
able to take this month off I've been
doing this for one the last six weeks in
particular have been insane you know
trying to get ready to because of the
show for people that are listening the
show is gonna continue to go on we
banked a ton of episodes and we worked
really hard to get them all locked and
loaded so the show will continue without
sa don't risk it without a break when
I'm gone
because of all the work that we did to
front-load it in the meantime but I'm
excited I'm a little nervous about the
whole thing and and let me just say that
you know just to check my privilege a
little bit like it's a gift that I get
to be able to give myself this
opportunity and I'm very aware and
realized that you know not everybody can
do that sure I'm grateful to have the
opportunity and it was something that
that I thought I was going to do last
year but I didn't take the steps
required in order to do it and the time
just passed and I just filled it up with
a bunch of stuff so it was like oh you
want to take a vacation okay you can do
that next year
I know it's like literally the plan for
this break began like in January of you
know a full year ago to get ready for it
so anyway well I hope you have an
amazing
amazing experience and I hope to find
you yeah sometime mid month so here we
are were were on this train headed into
the holiday season a lot of people I
would I think it's fair to say ourselves
included like experience a little bit of
anxiety extra anxiety and and stress and
perhaps even some distress around this
period of time because we find ourselves
in family situations that perhaps
trigger us in certain ways or bring up
old patterns and and despite our best
efforts or plans to not be reactive we
find ourselves reacting in an unhealthy
way repeating that cycle of unhealthy
behavior we feel compelled to overextend
ourselves by showing up for too many
people because we feel that's what's
expected of us and we feel ourselves
over consuming or over participating in
The Consumerist cycle that is baked in
to this time of year it's a trope to say
that every year the holiday season
starts earlier but it does like it used
to be an unwritten rule that no
Christmas music would be heard in any
retail store until Thanksgiving or the
day after Thanksgiving but I was in
Starbucks like 10 days ago like early
November and there were they were
playing Christmas music I think they
started before Halloween it's insane
it is absolutely insane and it's all
driven to get us to get our wallets in
our pocketbooks out and spend money that
either we don't have or we don't want to
have because we feel that's part of the
social contract that we signed up for so
help us find a healthier way to pass
through this triggering time of year
well as I always say triggering as I
always say this time of year is the
entire society has you know in in my in
my awareness deliberately put a an
opposing force on top of the natural
cycle of life so in December we see as
the Sun starts get getting
lower sooner and we start you know rich
and I at like 6:30 we're like good night
I'm going to bed it like when it when it
gets dark early I'm literally in bed at
8 o'clock yeah right and then if I have
to do something that keeps me up at
night and I'm in bed at like 10 I feel
lousy the next day I was like it's not
like I stayed up till 2:00 in the
morning no but the thing is is it's that
you know the the world is dark and the
inclination is then to retire to go
within it's an inner experience so when
you're coming into December the natural
cadence of life in the northern
hemisphere is that the days are getting
shorter and it's a time of inner
reflection it's when all of creation
comes to a death and then starts to be
reborn after the Solstice but instead we
have the superimposition of this
consumerism program which is telling you
that you should be spending more money
than you have if you just tap into the
feeling inside of yourself you're
spending money but inside of yourself it
feels like you shouldn't be spending
money it's an it's in fact exactly
counter it's like but you have this
program that tells you that if you don't
buy presents for all your loved ones
then you're not showing that you love
them and you get caught up in it and
it's kind of cool and you know we all
like elves and I like Santa Claus and
you know I like the beautiful tree with
the sparkling lights on it and they
become family traditions and so you know
I think they say that like most of
America spends the entire year paying
off their credit card debt for what they
spend for Christmas and if we look at
really the violence of that and the
suppression of that on a human being
just even energetically like if it's
just sitting there if that debt is
sitting there it is actually pulling
from the human pulling from the soul so
first of all just to recognize that this
counter force is there and that you can
sort of refine it or maybe recreate it
in a more simplistic way I'm not saying
you know don't buy any gifts you could
buy a gift for people you could just try
to simplify envision more creative ways
make up ways that you can share the gift
of experience instead of stuff so maybe
an amazing
dinner or an amazing treasure hunt or an
amazing you know offering of a play or a
song try to be more creative than the
mall or then Amazon or you know wherever
we normally go to satisfy these needs
the other thing is just being aware of
the landfill and what are you buying and
what is then going you know where is the
waste going there's so much waste so
much waste it is so strange that that
this holiday falls upon us at this time
of year because it is true like every
instinct in my body is to hibernate to
pull the sheets up to go with it to kind
of be a little bit more reclusive than I
wouldn't then I would ordinarily
and to kind of store the chestnuts to
get through the winter and yet were
compelled or sort of pressured into this
environment in which we have to do the
exact opposite it runs counter to our
natural rhythms and the cycle of this
time of year unless you're living in
you know Southie well that's one of the
reasons why you know well I can't reveal
but we're going to someplace with Sun
yeah you know and that was the reason
and I'm really interested I'm intrigued
to know that if you're I wonder if we're
in this if we're in the southern
hemisphere if you feel the same
energetic that's what interests what I
want to find I want to find out because
it doesn't the sun is shining
if it doesn't you and I are for the rest
of our lives we'll be in the southern
southern hemisphere during that time
because it's always a bummer and you're
it's always some people love it though I
don't know just for me like you know it
affects me deeply if in every December
I'm like what we should go somewhere
where it's not like this right now and
now we can you know but I would say also
like on the point of trying to be a
little bit more creative with the
gift-giving ethos some of the most
meaningful and fun times that we had
around this time of year with kids were
when we were literally flat broke and
penniless and we had to we we were
forced to be creative about what we were
going to do to get through this
experience and there were a couple years
where the rule was we're not buying
anything you have to make something
right and so we were compelled to get
creative trapper made a video like a
hilarious video that I still I wash it
recently it was so funny and that was a
long time ago we bought like super what
we did buy we bought super cheap cheap
t-shirts and then we painted them or we
painted a pair of like cheap sneakers or
whatever just to create like little art
pieces instead of like doing the normal
thing some of the most the most fun time
so for anybody who's going through a
dismantling or doesn't have flow right
now or it's really you know in in a
sacred moment that is challenging you
financially
please get creative and turn it into
something positive you will never forget
these times these times are special
actually and it's not really it's not
really expansive or the life experiences
that you remember the Christmases or the
holidays or whatever you celebrate where
you got more stuff you remember the more
meaningful things the dinner the play
the song the comedy skit whatever you're
able to create yeah I mean it also
amplifies that that thing where you're
measuring your experience against the
experience of others and I think that's
very shame provoking for a lot of people
like they can't I can't do it like that
or this guys do it look what he's doing
for you no it's just the whole thing is
like super unhealthy yeah definitely yes
what about going into the family
standard family situation yeah I mean
you know the thing is is obviously the
holidays are loaded we all know that the
families hold the biggest triggers for
all of us they installed the trigger
they installed they installed the bug
say you installed the trigger at a soul
level and then maybe shows this family
and they're providing the perfect so
what I wanted to do in this life I want
to be I want to have a button that makes
me go crazy when somebody says this
hopefully that provides you the
evolution so that you can clear whatever
that whatever that my azzam or that
imbalance is but though the big truth
I think is our friend and is an
opportunity for us to move beyond all
this assessment and judgment and
analysis of humans and our culture and
conditions and all kinds of things is to
understand that there is no consensus
there is great power in understanding
there is no consensus there is only one
of you in the entire multiverse there is
only one of every one of us in the
entire multiverse but if it's a
multiverse isn't aren't I having a
parallel experience somewhere else just
well yeah but what does that have to do
with this so and there's more than one
of me well yeah right but that is
there's another me having a totally
different experience in the in the
broader multiverse definitely and so do
you find solace and matter expansion and
I just do I understand your point my
point is is that for some reason humans
are always trying to have these long
discussions and and do analyses and
decide inside their mental construct
that a certain way is the way or you
know in this convenient ways of life
however you live there is no consensus
and when you understand there is no
consensus you can possibly stop trying
to feel triggered or wounded by your
family having another reality or another
truth if you understand that each person
will have their own perspective and they
have the right to have that perspective
you can just simply let go and just
rather than go into family dinners or
holiday gatherings where you're you know
with people from different political
parties or people for different dietary
lifestyles there's no reason to create
drama or emotional outburst for reasons
of differences of opinions or choices in
the way of being if you're centered in
yourself you have that peace and that
awareness so walk me through the
brasstacks of that of this let's say
you're you're getting the family you're
getting on a plane you're headed to this
you're gonna your Lane
in Cincinnati you're gonna go to this I
know I'm taking I'm just creating a you
know a an example uncle Jerry's gonna be
there you know he's probably gonna drink
too much like he always does and then
he's gonna say that thing and last time
he did this is what happened and and you
kind of know that that program is just
waiting for you and despite your best
intentions of having it go differently
this time you know you let it go you did
it I'm letting it go I'm okay fine and
then it just keeps going until finally
you're like all right I've had enough
and then you say the thing and then the
whole thing goes to [ __ ] right like I
think a lot of people can relate to some
version of that so in a very practical
way like how do you like what is it that
you have to do to avoid that pitfall or
stop yourself from doing the thing
that's contributing to the you know the
greater problem I mean ultimately it's
doing the inner work and all of that
outburst comes from you or us not giving
ourselves the attention the care the
recognition that we need and so my
spiritual mentorship program which is
called water tiger the reason that it's
called water tiger is it is all designed
to bring us into resonance with who we
are so that we can fall again in love
with who we are so when you when you
haven't taken care of yourself your
inner child or your needs or your wants
you are looking for validation from the
outside and many of us have this
wounding it's very very common and to
have that to need your parent to give
you that that validation and it goes on
into our 50s and 60s where we're you
know we're still waiting for our mom or
our father to say you matter you know
what I see you yeah I see you you know
and and you'll hear the it's it's not
the set up like it can be the set up if
you happen to have that really amazing
relationship with your parent which you
could or you could not but the point
that we're always waiting for that final
validation is just an illusion we we
have our attention in there
and you know focus in the wrong place if
we've taken the time to give ourself the
care to consider ourselves first to
understand that we matter to understand
that every single life forming creation
is being shined upon with equal
brilliance there is no discrimination
between different life forms
so why as human beings do we always
think we have to convince other people
to think how we think or receive
validation from the outside so that we
feel enough on the inside and so I do
this mirror practice and water tiger
where you actually go sit in the mirror
and you stare in your eyes and you
breathe and you face what is there and
there's a lot of things that come up for
people there's a lot of pain a lot of
Tears they start to see different
aspects of themselves but if they can
get through the discomfort of that they
can get to a deeper resonance and
alignment with who they are and
understand that you have the opportunity
and the responsibility to care for
yourself as if you were your most
beloved child and what we do is we take
all the focus outside of that and we're
looking for that validation to be given
from the outside so if you're fully
aligned in yourself and you understand
that this play is made up of billions of
different life forms
you could simply choose to view what was
his name uncle uncle Harry uncle Jerry
uncle Jerry you could just view uncle
Jerry I don't have an uncle Jerry so
uncle Jerry could just be like I'm a
tiger and I resonate with that and uncle
Jerry could just be you know an owl
right and when you're in that if he's a
rhino
so what then he's a rhino it's like
there's no reason you know a tiger is
not going to spend time feeling less
than or triggered because a rhino is
being a rhino like a rhino is just being
a rhino it's not it's not at me it's not
personal at me I'm unique and I have my
own way of moving through life sometimes
I'll want to dance with people and
that'll feel great
but I don't need them to be like me for
me to be valid right and that is it's a
huge thing and I mean this goes into
other topics you know in in our culture
and you know the dialogues that go on in
Twitter and that everybody's always
pontificating these huge conversations
about different points of view and it's
like you know my favorite Saint this
beautiful woman Sriman on Des Moines MA
one of my favorite quotes she said every
man is right from his own point of view
mm-hmm so every woman is right from her
own point of view so where is the
friction what are we doing it's nonsense
it's just nonsense and when you release
that need uncle Jerry is not gonna do
that thing
well Jerry gonna be Jerry right and and
and there's nothing you could do about
it or you should do about yeah that the
point is the path to freedom is
releasing your need for Jerry to be any
different than Jerry already is and to
focus on the only thing that you can
control which is your reaction or
response to Jerry or to the environment
that you choose to you know move
yourself into right and the more that
you can kind of be carry that conscious
awareness into these tricky environments
and the more grounded and centered that
you can become by virtue of mindfulness
practices a meditation practice sealing
your field which is something that you
know you've taught me and that I've done
and we've talked about on this podcast
you you are in a better position to
whether those tricky situations by being
nonreactive like you have a choice you
don't have to react to whatever that
person says you don't have to prove them
wrong or to prove that you're right or
to need the validation of anybody else
you can just sit in your space anchor
yourself in your seat and if you have to
you don't have to say anything but the
more nonreactive you can be and the more
mindfully responsive you can be you're
in a better position to have a different
experience and the power rests within
you too
change or break that old paradigm and
dynamic that continues to repeat itself
every year don't wait for somebody else
to make a different choice or to handle
things differently don't point your
finger across the table at somebody and
say you did it again that power is is
within you but and it yes and then let's
take it even a level let's even be more
powerful and let's take it a level
beyond that let's take it to an
observational place and a recognition
that every life-form is divine and that
means that uncle Jerry in his state of
awareness at this point in this identity
is also divine it is not for you to
judge and so what if you were able to
observe Jerry in his process with
unconditional love and acceptance not
like I'm gonna make the right move and
then I'm gonna be in a better place or
or look at me like maybe I'm quietly
judging him but I didn't say anything
how great am i yes so that's not energy
is something so you're not there if
that's where you are so if you can
really just let it go and understand and
trust in the play of life you can just
allow events to have unfold allow people
to be who they are and understand with
compassion and love that each person is
divine and each person is a form of some
sort of divinity or aspect of God
consciousness even if they're not awake
or they're not choosing to experience
something that is in alignment with you
and if you if you if you truly embody
this though the triggers will simply
melt away and there are chances are that
uncle Jerry will meet you in a
completely different way than you ever
dreamed possible because these energies
are things and they're triggering their
plane off of each other and another
thing to really keep in mind over the
holidays and all times is it as a very
prudent practice to avoid explosive
confrontation always and the reason is
in
awareness there are actually life-forms
that eat this explosion if if if you
really explode on somebody and you know
I've had that experience you can feel
the level of darkness that is in that
you can feel what's going on so we want
to not be triggered into those
situations because they really do have a
dark energy around them and if you want
to be a representative for higher
vibration on planet Earth or a higher
vision of eating of wellness if you want
to be that type of person that includes
staying in neutral loving compassion and
not participating in creating more of
this dark energy that is plentiful on
planet earth which we certainly don't
need more of I think it's also worth
saying that if you don't feel like you
are spiritually and emotionally fit to
handle that task you have the power to
decline the end with the invitation
there's so much pressure on people like
well every year this is what we do and
so I have to go and the truth is you
don't and just because these people are
your family members and you're measuring
your experience with your family against
some idyllic imagined you know paradigm
of what a family is a healthy family is
supposed to look like and feeling bad
because yours doesn't measure up to that
and you feel like you you're you're not
going to be able to handle it in an
emotionally healthy way then I think
it's also ok to let people know to give
them permission like listen you know
you're you have to look out for yourself
first and if you don't feel like this is
in your best interest to do this like
it's okay if you take a pass and you
know this is something that I've learned
in the secret society rooms of recovery
like you know this time of year is the
most loaded loaded of the you know like
people who are trying to stay sober you
know relapse
you know people that are active in their
disease it becomes additionally inflamed
you know disproportionately inflamed
around this time of year you know
because of these dynamics and they
become so uncomfortable for people that
they feel like the only way they can do
it is if they numb themselves out and
use so if you are struggling with some
form of substance problem it's okay to
opt out like if you have to if you feel
like that's jeopardizing your ability to
stay sober or not take that drink or do
that thing then you know your well-being
is more important than you taking a seat
across the table from Uncle Terry yeah
absolutely and I mean that falls under
the first step and that is self-care you
you must be there for yourself first and
make sure that you're fulfilled you're
cared for you're protected you're
nurtured you have to because no one else
is going to do that for you nor should
they you should be every decision you
make should be how does this affect my
being my inner child my little child is
this an alignment for him is this an
alignment for her what is what would be
the most nurturing act for her that's
where you begin and when you use shift
that that order of priority then the
universe shifts that order yeah I think
people feel I mean it brings up you know
emotions of guilt like I can't know I
had you don't understand it like I have
to go like if I don't go like this is
gonna happen and this is gonna happen
and that's gonna happen so it's just
easier for me to go even if you know
like I know I probably it's not in my
best interest like the expectation level
is just too high and I don't want to
deal with the fallout well it is it is a
real thing you know it is a real thing
because when you shift your behavior
that causes the other energies to jump
up don't expect to be celebrated for
that well it really has to be a personal
choice I mean you have to be able to
stand sovereign in your choice and this
is where the mirror work comes in
is when you've really received yourself
and really looked at what you're sitting
in what is your spirit sitting in and
you've gone through all the things that
you'll owe then all the shame and all
the trauma that's in there from this
life from other lives when you actually
sat with it and looked at it and
resolved it you start to get more and
more power but I would say overall even
if you choose to go and you're not ready
to make that stance and you feel it to
be too volatile again your power is in
neutral loving compassion just be
neutral it's fine you know and you'd be
surprised how powerful this practice is
yeah you got a channel some Yoda energy
yeah doesn't matter
Jedi isn't like getting into a political
argument at a festive holiday gathering
the Jedi is not allowing himself to be
emotionally agitated by other people
Jedi is constantly in a mindful state of
neutrality yeah exactly and that's the
best place from which to you know
basically exhibit the best version of
who you are yeah exactly and you know
people are on their own timelines so in
our own family you know here we are you
know wellness leaders advocates you know
created over 500 vegan recipes you know
Sri Moo do life and you know just
recently you know it's some of my family
members my brothers like hey I think I'm
gonna go vegan you know it's been like
10 years so you know but everybody's on
their timeline and now in this document
yeah I know it's calming yeah I mean
that's the perfect thing isn't it I mean
our fit your family your birth family
usually at least in our generation
doesn't see doesn't see who's sitting
inside their family and also many of us
who came to create a new way it's a
setup
we incarnated into families that we are
not like vibration because that's where
the transformation happens so many of us
feel like black sheep
many of us feel lonely feel
misunderstood isolated I would say
that's probably been historically the
biggest pain of in my life to be MS
understood and not seen for who I am
yeah I think it's very common
I felt that way most of my life and a
big part of the growth curve and the
evolution is in the realization that I'm
not looking to my family members to
resolve that for me well because I don't
I'm not I'm not outsourcing that job of
getting comfortable with myself to other
people but you've done that because
you've developed yourself because you've
had all this because it's like very you
know the trope of a in some job you
couldn't do that very well before you
had done that so again it goes back to
the self work and the experience you
could call it years experience but also
really the focus of your answer the
answer to your evolution is inside your
own being yeah so those anybody else
from the outside it's just irrelevant it
just doesn't matter and I think I mean
I'm certainly seen as I've gotten older
how suddenly these competitions within
my siblings are just dissolving because
suddenly you know you're not nobody's
vying for the attention or you know one
of my father's passed away and my
mother's you know 92 and it's just
things change and they become irrelevant
you know and then suddenly you're like
yeah suddenly you're like hey what's up
like it's just not it's just not what it
was like it's so loaded when we're
younger we're just looking for that
validation like see me see me see me see
me and you hear so many stories from
people that say you know my mother is
still hoping that I get a real job you
know things like I you know you
experienced that as well of course my
mom still wants you to be a doctor I
think right yeah I mean it's like 53 now
you know what I mean like the the bit
the larger point is these patterns
become entrenched like whatever that
wounding is or that pain point that you
experienced as a young person in a
dynamic with another individual albeit
your sister your mom your dad your
brother whoever these things then repeat
and get played out like thousands and
thousands of times through adulthood so
you're you know in your 50s and a
dynamic that you have with a sibling is
exactly the same
as when you were like you know six and
ten or whatever and then having that
awareness is the first step to resolving
it but then you have to really do the
inside work to kind of transcend that
and not not just fall prey into kind of
doing what you always do it's hard it's
really hard but identifying like
understanding what that core wound is
first like how did this begin like when
did we start doing this in why and then
realizing like it's ridiculous where our
50s now why are we still in this dance
but you can't even realize it because
you you have to clear the trauma you
have to have face yourself and fine it
because you can't intellectually make it
go away it's not going to and the thing
that that is happening to humanity is
these our ancestral patterns that are
being handed down from generation to
generation and without spiritual
awakening they are causing a recycling
so you're just going to drop this body
take another life and you'll come back
with the same issues over and over and
over again and so this is the moment of
spiritual awakening this is the moment
in history that we're at and this is the
opportunity and so this is why the
devotion to spiritual practice to really
really going deep inside your own being
and finding out who you are clearing the
trauma clearing the addictions claiming
your sovereignty this is the moment
we're at and if you don't resolve them
they will continue through lifetime
after lifetime after lifetime and they
generally they don't just continue they
tend to become amplified certainly right
until you reach a crisis point that
forces your compels you to confront it
so now those are the lucky ones actually
the people that kind of just repeat it
and it's a low-grade kind of problem are
never you know in enough pain to
actually look at it like that's what
they you know people in the secret so
I'm a grateful alcoholic I'm a grateful
drug addict because the drugs are so
it's so like this is something I talk
about with Russell Brand he's like well
clearly you know it's the heroin like
you know if you're it's gonna come to an
end because it's so obvious what your
dilemma is what your problem
so the drug addicts are actually the
lucky ones because they're forced to
confront this thing and it sends them it
kind of catalyzes this trajectory of
self-discovery but short of that if
you're struggling with something that is
impeding you know negatively
you know it's negatively in fact
impacting your life in some way but it's
it it doesn't percolate up into becoming
a full-blown crisis you could just sort
of weather it for the rest of your life
and never really look out yeah that's
very true and I mean it's also stated
and you know spiritual evolution as well
that you know the dark someone with a
lot of dark energy has a lot more
opportunity to self realize in in some
cases than someone who's just sort of
like you know flat line right because
you're right because then that could
never that could never sort of activate
that catalyst moment so yeah it's very
very true yeah so if you're in a dark
moment I always say that if you're
really really really blessed at least
once in your life you will have a
profound sacred moment pain is the great
lever and all of this but the truth is
is that the choice is always available
to you because everybody knows what
their the thing is that they need to
look at you know on some level some
level of conscious awareness and the
choice is available to you to confront
it or deal with it it's just easier when
it when it blows up in your face and
then you have no choice you have to this
is something I've been pondering lately
a lot and and it's like what if
everything that you did really mattered
like really had a big impact and you
know you look at the modern life and
what we're in and and how our life goes
in our days and it's it's very easy to
be lazy it's very easy to just when you
have space turn on Netflix it's very
easy to medicate with food or drugs or
alcohol or sex or you know talking
incessant talking and pontificating
about different various topics and
political stances and then feel as if
you participated and you did something
that was you know catalyzing change or
evolving it's it takes diligence to
commit to
spiritual practice meditation
observation within yourself self inquiry
refining your diet using movement of the
body to actually understand that this is
a body temple it takes diligence you
know I was talking to a friend today who
was talking to me about how he hasn't
had as much evolution as that he wanted
and it's like I had to point out to him
that he's kind of been on the sidelines
he's not really in the commitment of
saying to the universe I am here I am
showing up for this and it's a practice
and it's it's really a thing because
these moments are very very precious and
so what if it did matter every single
thing you did every day what if there
was no like downtime where I'm just
gonna you know I'm just gonna eat this
lollipop or I'm just gonna watch this
crime show cuz I like it
that's what I like I like crime show
like what if every single make no but
I'm I'm I am and I'm not I mean the
thing you know myself you know like I'll
have this feeling like oh I had this big
expansion you know now you know I'm
gonna check out for a while like how is
it that we're checking out and what if
we understood how precious every moment
of this life was and what you know
everybody has the same 24 hours in the
day at least in this realm so you know
time is a funny thing but you know
that's something I've been I've been
really pondering and I guess it's coming
to my awareness with my connection with
Dom in her spiritual community and in
Italy near Tonino
and Falco the founder you know they were
they were doing some experiments and
time travel and they would move simply a
stone from one position to the other
position and that would change a
trajectory of history and so that
brought into my awareness just how
important everything we do the way we do
things our intention when we do things
how are we spending that downtime and
really how important is that crime show
like is it what are we doing with our
attention if we are powerful create
creators which we are
so we live in a quantum world and we're
choosing to place our intention on a
scenario that is not expansive for
Humanity and we're sometimes that can be
for an exploration to learn about
something that's an out-of-balance
so that we can formulate a solution and
so it's not having blinders on and not
knowing what's going on but this brings
me to a tendency in the culture is to
call out all the problems that are going
on which makes the ego feel really
justified because the egos taken a
stance but if we are in fact quantum
being beings and we're only calling out
the problems and looking for everything
that is lacking and how are we
participating in the upliftment of our
world and what if I've talked about this
before so we are all Christic beings or
we are we are Christ beings and not in a
religious sense in a spiritual sense and
so the real meaning of being a Christ is
holding something in a higher vision
despite appearances to the contrary so
I've done that with through our life
with the transition and the the
evolution of our house and going through
financial collapse and me holding this
vision and serving that with ceremony
and commitment coming back and back to
it again and again and again no matter
how many lawyers and how many business
people told me I was crazy I still held
it it was like six years or five years
that I did that the crazy person in the
room and then that reality came to
fruition and we're here now same thing
mr. wash who was one of the speakers out
original thinkers held this vision that
he would be released from a life
sentence in prison painted it into a
painting I may have talked about this
before but just to understand that he
was quantumly participating in creating
the world he wanted to create so I ran
into David Holbrooke who's the founder
of original thinkers at Mercado sagrada
original thinkers is is an ideas
festival kind of like aspen ideas
festival or ted that takes place in
telluride that we we
and an amazing amazing amazing festival
and so many good creative beautiful
human beings doing amazing things on
planet earth and and I was speaking to
him and he was asking me you know what
do you think about next year and so
we're gonna have a meeting in December
but I told him you know where is the
vision what are what have what are we
creating and not that I want to make a
grand consensus because that will be
very multi-layered because we're all
different life forms but what are we
committing to as feeling beings that
want a different reality on earth we
want our waters clean we want our
animals cared for we want ourselves
healthy we want our starving children
fed we want the pedophilia to be gone
from this planet what are we doing to
hold the higher vision this is the
moment we have all the energy here to
support us and I see so many people just
talking about the problems the problems
the problems of problems and then going
away and where is the beauty so I think
this is the mission this is the task or
the opportunity that we have right now
and to spend times as we've shared about
our experience how do you create a
beautiful experience in your life you
spend time doing the things that you
love because that creates a loving field
and that becomes magnetic so how can we
take that feeling and then roll it out
to all of our individual missions
Reema's a part of my mission your
podcasting your you know your books and
your writings that's a part of your
vision and all of us have a piece all of
us have something to share but can we
understand that we are quantum beings
and that we are creating this and I
don't mean put your head in the sand and
say it's all unicorns and rainbows and
we're gonna skip away together I'm not
talking about that we know we're in a
planetary realm that has tremendous
levels of you know my azzam and dark
happenings that are happening in this
realm so I'm not an illusion but I'm
saying we are the quantum he
we are the quantum masters let's step
into that and let's let's make an
experiment and let's see what we can do
and if we don't succeed well at least we
tried
at least we at least we got together and
said hey let's do that or let's let's
make an agreement that we're going to
tweet or post you know 98% positive
information and not send any of the
negative you know I don't know I that's
you know social media is not the answer
but it no I mean like an idea yeah it's
not I mean I think there's a Obama
talked about this and that clip that I
shared and I think you retweeted as well
this idea this illusion that if you're
attacking people on social media or you
know standing in judgment of others that
you're you're really only serving your
own ego you know and and you're you're
you're creating this illusion that
you've actually done something when you
actually haven't done anything so
tweeting positive things is great but
what are you actually doing in your life
right let's transcend the digital space
to actually be functional in the
solution of the things that you know ALS
culturally right now we need more of
that and I think that you're you know
spot-on and those other observations
we're on the precipice now tonight I'm
going to be sharing the podcasts that I
did with John and Molly Chester of
apricot lane farms they're the people
behind the documentary the biggest
little farm so if you're listening to
this that show has already gone up and
you're aware that I've posted that and
this has been a tricky you know it's on
the subject of of other people's
judgment and and and you know negative
you know perspectives on things because
there was a certain contingent of the
vegan community that was very unhappy
that I visited this farm and chose to
engage these people in a conversation
around climate change and and
regenerative farming practices and
carbon sequestration and soil health and
all of these things and you
disheartening like I understand like
look I'm vegan I've been vegan for 12
years I chose not to participate in this
cycle of animal harm a long time ago but
I'm also very conscious that these
issues are not binary they're more
complicated than that
and you know this is a couple who left
their urban existence in Santa Monica to
try to do something they weren't gonna
tweet how the soil is being depleted
they actually went and bought a farm and
tried to repair the soil imagine that
yeah and and you know along the way they
made a choice that that I would like to
believe I wouldn't make which is to sell
a few of their animals for food from
time to time and because of that there's
a section of the vegan community that
was very unhappy with me and my choice
to have a conversation with these people
and and that's disheartening to me
because these are people who have a lot
of experience in what it's what's
actually required when you put your
hands in the dirt to sequester that
carbon and be in the solution of climate
change and I have a lot of respect for
that and I have empathy for that so back
to uncle Jerry sitting across from the
table I am NOT sitting in judgment of
these people in fact I'm expressing
empathy for them and that empathy
doesn't necessarily have to be tied to
an endorsement of every single belief
and behavior that they engage in but I
can celebrate some things that they're
doing that I think are worthy of notice
and worthy of being celebrated
absolutely I mean the thing is is that
these individuals and it was from the
love of their dog actually they had a
dog that would that wouldn't stop
barking and isn't this isn't yeah so
they ended up yeah like that they got
evicted from their apartment in Santa
Monica and they were like we need to
find a place for our dog and the dog had
like a name like Tony like a very human
so yeah so they created this farm really
for this dog and it's turned into this
10 year you know expression and you know
myself I you know I have no experience
growing food I have no experience with
soil you know we have three acres here
that it's our dream to develop it to you
know we've left it why
so we use hardly any water but but we're
not we're not we're armed we're not in
the process of you know replenishing the
soil or podcasting and making vegan
cheese so I'll go on Twitter and talk
about soil regeneration and climate
change and I can have conversations with
amazing people that help spread that
message but my hands are not in the dirt
right and so the thing is is that's your
that's your skill right that's your
divine design and their divine design is
that they created this whole ecosystem I
mean I saw I didn't see the whole movie
but I saw some of the footage and it's
like they have like whole like you know
flocks of birds returning I mean the
thing is just thriving it's crazy what
they've created now I'm not I wouldn't
make the choice to slaughter the animal
it's not it's not what I'm doing
but I'm looking at everything that
they're doing right the they have soul I
have so much to learn from them so much
to learn from them how would I how would
I ever judge them how would I ever be in
judgment of them I just I couldn't be so
everyone has to understand that when we
wake up we're causing harm I had this
question come up in my community call
just a couple days ago and it was about
this question of veganism and you know
what's right and what's wrong and I
would bring it back to yourself and say
that every single act that you
participate in in any lifetime in any
realm you will have to reconcile that
Act and so it's really about you and you
how are you know is that an alignment
for you and this is one of the reasons
maybe that I haven't been embraced by
the vegan community is because I was
raised in Alaska my dad was a hunter and
even though I was a child and I was
raised you know with meat and then later
when I discovered yoga I stopped eating
meat just naturally I still never really
made a statement or a declaration like I
don't really consider myself vegan I am
a feeling connected being whose
spontaneously makes decisions in the
moment and I've always said that if my
body told me that it needed meat as
medicine
I would find the cleanest meat I would
do a prayer over it eat it in reverence
until I didn't need it anymore now
that's never happened and I don't
foresee it happening but I don't like I
think when we bring violence into our
choices and we're using them to separate
ourselves from people we really miss and
for you to be attacked because you
showed the sustainable practices of this
farm is just very short-sighted and and
that's you know I've said this before
like if we bring violence into the
kitchen over our food choices we've
missed the entire point so again it's
not my choice
I love plant-based lifestyle and that's
why I created Sri Moo obviously I'm very
focused for the planet but each
individual has to make those decisions
for themselves mm-hmm yeah be
interesting to gauge the reaction of
this podcast I mean the truth is the
overwhelming you know response when I
posted on Instagram was was positive and
these themes these subjects regenerative
farming sustainable agriculture this is
this is a theme that is recurring all
the time on the show and echoed by a lot
of my guests including Zak Bush who's a
huge favorite on the show
Ryle and Englehart behind Cafe Gratitude
I'm putting up that episode soon David
Bronner all kinds of people that that
the audience embraces are basically
saying the same thing which is the
solution that we seek is underneath our
feet and there is a process there is a
way to live in that solution and these
are people that are doing it and I
wanted to understand that better and and
and celebrate that aspect of what it is
that they do yeah definitely and the
other thing that isn't being really
recognized is the fact that the
interaction is two-way
so you go into the farm and they
interact with you and you interact with
them who knows maybe in six months they
make an adjustment that means that they
you know harvest less animals and they
were or maybe it affects them deeply
just
presence simply the fact that you went
there maybe there's another solution I
don't know well I think overall it's
about broadening our aperture and
understanding that nothing is binary we
have this tendency to believe there's a
right and there's a wrong and there's a
black and there's a white and you said
it earlier like none of us is immune
from doing harm like we're all
perpetrating harm there are all negative
consequences to the fact that we're
living beatings on planet earth and
there's this there's a tendency among
certain people to develop an ego
attachment to a particular type of
lifestyle and what that becomes a
hardening and a judgment of other people
and I think that that is unhealthy and I
think that the more that we can
understand that we're all human beings
having a spiritual experience and we're
having our journeys and and and the more
empathy that we can have for other
people and the more humility that we can
engender when we go into social
interactions from a place of you know
coming from the heart and and an
openness like a growth mindset so like
learn from another human being then I
think that that is the solution you know
to a lot of what ails us and what we see
being played out in social media like we
all know that our information diet is
really important it's gonna dictate you
know a lot of our opinions and
worldviews so if you're you know
politically right your Twitter feed is
gonna look a certain way if you're a
progressive liberal you're gonna have a
completely different newsfeed is that
it's gonna you know basically channel
you everything that affirms your
worldview well it's no different in
health and nutrition if you're a keto
person or a low-carb person or a
carnivore person your feed is going to
basically be a constant stream of people
that see the world the way that you do
and practice what you practice if you're
a vegan that feed is going to be very
differently and these camps are becoming
further and further separated and
entrenched in their views because
there's no cross-pollination and so my
effort and my interest in going to
people like John and Molly Chester is to
participate
in that cross pollenization to have the
humility to understand like these people
know a lot about a certain thing that I
talk about all the time on the podcast
and I want to learn more about that not
from the perspective of a doctor or a
politician or an academic but from
people who are actually practitioners
who are doing this day in and day out
that was the spirit in which I I you
know went into that experience and I'm
glad that I did and I would do it again
and so it's disheartening to be attacked
for that and I get it the vegans are a
passionate community of people nobody
wants to see animals harmed but to say
that I'm endorsing the slaughter of
animals because I wanted because I was
curious and I followed that curiosity to
learn something and then share it is a
disheartening perspective yeah
definitely definitely so so I don't want
to end it here we go this year but like
what's what's looks like take people out
with no I mean you and I from the very
beginning when we entered into this
experiment and this expression we've
only shared our only our own experience
we're not here to tell anybody what we
always say that and also this lifestyle
is aspirational and it's a moving
changing evolving living form so we're
gonna learn new things find new ways
it's not a stasis or a state of
achievement that then you hold on to you
know with a hardness and a closed
mindedness it's it's an open moving
breathing experience of life and we all
have things to learn from each other yes
we all need to eat more plants yes we
need to stop this brutal suffering of
animals and industrial agriculture you
know yes we need to save our oceans and
but we've always had an open door and so
all of our cookbooks have been open to
any kind of eater it's never been an ism
for you and for me and Sri mu is what I
call universal it's vegan Paley
dairy free gluten free kosher for all
purposes
I'm sure it's Quito - because there's no
car so it's kind of everything it's just
for everyone and if we can eat more
plants and you know as Paul Hawken said
you know face plant rich lifestyle you
know it's going to be doing good and
everybody has to account and answer to
their own actions so nobody gets out of
anything
it will all be accounted for so we can
relax and you know do the best that we
can do to serve our own individual
awareness but again we need this
interaction and this Brotherhood and
sisterhood we need to not be separated I
was at an event yesterday and the girl
next to be speaking has a bone broth
company and I was sitting very close to
her and all I was emanating for her was
just love and listening to her and she
has her own experience every woman is
right from her own point of view every
man is right for his own point of view
yeah so and the thing is actually it's
funny because some of those people
actually even came on my feed trying to
get me to have you answer like this
means rich endorses animal brutality
really I was like really is that what it
means so now you're a proxy exact like
even if it's for like I talked to a guy
yesterday who talked to another guy who
talked to another guy who knows a guy
that works at you know a chicken factory
so I'm endorsing it it's like it's
insane it's insane but the thing is this
is and we have to remember this also as
individual creators and those of us who
came here to you know be the sacred
makers in our own fields and and put
things out in the world we need to not
be affected by that judgement and by
those swords that are that are thrown we
really need to understand that when you
act in alignment so you just said a
minute ago you said I would I stand by
what I do I would make the same decision
again that's your answer so you didn't
do something that was out of alignment
with who you are and your intentions
were in high alignment with your mission
of
a higher way of living on planet earth
there's no question about that
you weren't compromised you didn't
receive money you didn't like there was
no compromise no compromising your
integrity you did what is in alignment
with you and you would do it again and
that's the end of the conversation yeah
I follow that I did I did what I've done
from day one which is follow my
curiosity that's it I'm not here to
serve the best interests of a Dogma you
know like I'm not he you know some I'll
get criticism saying like I can't
believe you have non-vegans on your
podcast it's like I choose to eat plants
it's a lifestyle that I've adopted that
serves me well I think there's
tremendous benefits in this for personal
health for environmental health for for
animal welfare and the like and I'm
happy to talk about it and I talk about
it all the time but I don't define
myself by that alone aren't we all more
expansive beings I'm here to learn about
all different kinds of things I want to
be exposed to new ideas across the board
I'm not here to just focus on this one
issue I'm not a single issue voter or a
single issue focused individual and I
think we all need to kind of understand
that that it's important to realize that
we're bigger than these labels that we
attach to ourselves that make us feel
like we belong because there's an
identification there to a certain group
that makes us feel like we're part of
something and I understand that like I
get all that but there's more going on
but again if if we really care about the
planet and we care about our life and we
want to lift this experience higher it's
about the interaction with many diverse
life-forms so I think in soil
regeneration diversity is a key
underlying foundational power which
creates a healthy environment we have to
bring that awareness of diversity into
our own life forms yeah that's a great
point
right I mean it's all about diversity
the the in the narrative of the movie
it's like none of this works until you
get to this tipping
point in biodiversity and then it
becomes like this thriving thing that
becomes self-perpetuating to get it to
that point was very difficult but
fundamentally that's what it's all about
and I think there's a teacher in that
and the teacher is that that diversity
is necessary to a holistic well-being of
the larger ecosystem right and the more
that we can practice that and
participate in that emotionally that is
also the path towards the greater
well-being of the ecosystem of the
population well and what if we took all
that focus or that energy that is in
fighting for this thing this flag that
you're flying or this truth or this is
amor this Dogma or whatever you think
this intellectual stasis point is what
if we took that energy and instead you
gave it to yourself and you went and
loved yourself and you inquired within
yourself and you found out what you love
to do when you were a child and you made
a commitment to yourself I'm gonna be
here for you and I'm going to guide you
and and help you and protect you to
express everything that you want to and
you are loved you're a valued what if we
took that and brought it in instead of
all that focus of protecting something
that's not even a thing it's just an
illusion it's a made up it's a made up
construct and you know if you're
fighting for peace you're still fighting
I think Gandhi said that I'm thinking
I'm not sure somebody said it but if
you're fighting for anything you're
still fighting so what if we stop
fighting and just realize there is no
consensus there are billions of
life-forms that are interacting here and
so how can we come to each other when
we're not the same and instead of be in
judgment and analysis and separation
what if we just said please show me more
of who you are show me I'm so interested
I'm so curious tell me who you are why
is it that you feel that way how is it
that you feel when you experience and
express your own divinity or whatever
your life
we need to soften these edges and
understand that we all share this planet
we're all riding on this planet together
and the controller forces that want us
to to you know fight and and not rise up
they are putting these diverse energies
into the population they want us
fighting they want us focused on
fighting did you ever remember there was
like a fairy tale book that I had and I
think the one was called the stubborn
sillies or something and it was a man
and a wife who got in a fight and they
were both had their arms crossed and
they were not looking at each other and
while they were doing that a thief came
in and stole everything that they had
and so in a way we're fighting and then
these thieves are stealing our life from
us they're stealing our livelihood so
it's really within our power to imagine
vision and then get into action creating
the world that we want to experience
here together this is a magnificent
planet and human beings are feeling
creative connected empathic loving
amazing individuals and when we have
knowledge we have a power that can never
be taken from us when we remember who we
are that we are divine and when you
enter into that awareness you have so
much power and so much creativity and so
much energy with which to create and so
this is really the time and we are the
ones we've been waiting for you are the
one you've been waiting for it's not
someone else coming powerful Srimati
closing it down with the truth and the
wisdom so I want everybody to remember
that when you're sitting across your
Thanksgiving or holiday table from your
version of uncle Jerry root yourself in
your experience have patience practice
empathy and compassion and hopefully you
can have a different and joyous
experience
what do you think I think so I can see
it I'm gonna hold that vision a vision
that's hold that vision let's not hope
let's hold that vision cool well always
a pleasure thank you my dear
rich I said darling oh darling here here
all right thank you my darling
good talk how do you feel I feel good do
you think it was good no it's good okay
if you want to learn more about Julie
pyat aka Srimati she is at Srimati on
twitter and instagram if you want to
learn more about the cheese Sri moo.com
is the place to go for that and that's
it
have a happy holiday everybody I'm
taking off I'll catch you on the flip
side shows will go up as they always do
on schedule but I'm gonna be taking care
of myself and I'll see you in the secret
place you will you will after I ship all
my orders
alright peace namaste
[Music]